regi good morning to you I love your
story and I can't wait for you to share
it with everyone at home let's take it
back to the age of 18 and you gotta put
a council estate in London
dad wasn't around you've been excluded
from school and had a bit of trouble
with the law and then there was a
turning point what was it so at 17 years
old so I sanity football contract at 16
and halfway through that contrast I
didn't want to play football anymore
because my dad had just passed away and
that put even more financial strain on
my family so when I decided that I
didn't want to play football anymore
because football's all eggs one basket I
had to find another way to take my
family out of the environment that we
grew up in and because I didn't really
focus on education I didn't know if I
was good at math English or science I
said what way can I find out the skills
and quality people had to amass their
wealth and that's when I decided to
research in Google wealthiest areas in
London and I made a list of places
Kingston and Chelsea wish was having you
and three other places and I went near
started asking a question so that is
literally what you did you went to these
areas and you literally started knocking
on doors and one woman took a chance on
you not only open the door but let you
into her home to give you the benefit of
her and her husband's experience who
were they what did they tell you so it
was the price family I knocked on the
door and initially she was speaking for
the intercom and said this is part of a
school project I said no I'm literally
doing it off my own back I just want to
know what skills and qualities you had
so I can take that for myself go back to
where I'm from use it and hopefully
become as well for you do to live in
Sarah so she invites me and half-free
for our conversation her husband walks
in and he's name was Quinton price so
Quinton was the head of Alpha strategies
at Blackrock which is an investment
management firm and he was just so
welcoming he took time to speak to me
was giving me great advice and he
invited me to Blackrock about two weeks
later for an inside day so I was in
college at the time but then he invited
me to an undergraduate inside day and
that's when I was exposed to fine as my
first time in the sea and I only lived
25 minutes away from the city and from
there I enjoyed my day and he invited me
back for a week-long work experience in
the summer completed that
and I had a meeting with him my mum and
another mentor Michael Nathan and that's
when I asked him okay Quinton I really
enjoyed my time here what do I have to
do to work in the management center and
he encouraged me to go to university and
study something finance related to give
me the best chance at becoming the most
competitive candidate so apprenticeships
a degree you're now working at legal and
in general in a successful role there
you know at 23 you could think I've done
my bit earning a good living I'm on my
way up but you're actually giving back
and you're talking about mentors that
you had and now you're very keen for you
know young boys and girls who are
watching at home now to have the same
kind of opportunity and drive that you
had so tell us about your mentoring
you're giving back definitely I
personally feel like I could just stop
where I am but it's maybe the visibility
side of things because I just feel like
people that come up in a generation
especially from socially challenged
backgrounds if they don't have the
visibility to say I can become a bank or
a lawyer or anything really
they can't aspire to be that so what I'm
trying to do is just give them that
visibility to say you know you can do it
if you want to do it and giving them the
soft skills and the capabilities for
them to go into that sector and do it so
I am now a group chair of ACCA mode and
talent which is helping undergraduates
to become more competitive I do a lot of
mentoring in a youth organization in
East London called a victory youth group
I have my own mentoring called k3d again
helping sixth form students and
undergraduates to just become more
competitive and I also travel to schools
and colleges and universities up and
down the country you know sharing my
story but also speaking about social
issues that we face and how to improve
it what would be your one piece of
advice to any teen who has perhaps
fallen out of the education system has
perhaps had you know a brush with the
law doesn't have role models what would
you say to them I know it sounds quite
cliche but I would just say you can
actually do anything you want to do and
that's coming from someone who only
started studying properly at the age of
17 18 and is now working in in the city
of London so one thing I was just saying
is you can do anything you want to do
just keep your head down have good
people around you and if you can find
someone that is a mentor
or an accountability partner that can
help you to get where you are and you
know for me it worked
I had Quintin and I've met many more
people on the way and if I can be the
next Quintin for someone else or someone
else can go and find their Quintin and
you know that will make the world of
difference I just feel like mentoring
and providing that visibility for the
younger generation makes a world of
difference it's never too late to stop
and make that change Reggie it's been an
absolute pleasure to meet you this early
thank you so much for coming in and
sharing your story really is
inspirational not just for teens but for
adults out there well Reggie Nelson